s'il est un enfant chéri du festival de
cannes c'est bien lui après son tout
premier film à la quinzaine des
réalisateurs il ya tout juste dix ans il
se retrouve quatre fois en sélection
officielle à moins de 30 ans il avait
déjà reçu un prix du jury un grand prix
est aussi un prix du jury oecuménique et
une queer palm pas pour le même film je
le précise il est à nouveau en
compétition cette année avec mathias et
maxime un film d'amour comme on en fait
rarement dans lequel il interprète l'un
des deux rôles principaux mathias et
maxime sont deux amis d'enfance au coeur
d'une bande de copains pour les besoins
d'un court métrage il vous de voir
s'embrasser et tout va changer
xavier dolan et mon invité bonjour vous
aviez qu'est ce que ça change quand vous
jouez dans un de nos films mais ça
change tout puis ça change rien en même
temps parce que je les ai déjà fait dans
le passé et puis je suis quelqu'un qui
en tout cas je pense je j'ai pas de
difficultés comme acteur à détester ce
que j'ai fait ah c'est vrai ou à
apprendre à aimer puis à dire ok on
bouge on passe à la prochaine scène où
puis-je entouré de gens je lui parle
d'emploi d'un point de vue technique à
savoir est ce que on est satisfait avec
ce qui était ce qui était jouée ce qui
était fait comment ça a été interprété
je suis entouré de gens très
bienveillant qui sont capables d'être je
veux peut être cruel parce qu'ils sont
toujours délicats mais qui sont capables
d'être très franc qui ne m'achète pas ou
qui me meut me donne pas de compliments
inutiles ou donc donc qu'ils sont
toujours sincère avec moi qui peux vous
le dire non c'était et votre direction
d'acteurs est ce qu'elle est différente
quand vous jouez ou pas dans votre film
parlant de votre chef opérateur andré
turpin est ce qu'il ya un rôle différent
lorsque vous êtes dans le film mais il a
un rôle de confident comme comme come
dancing grains de la productrice comme
comme la comme la scripte nathalie
paquet comme les tous les gens dont je
sollicite toujours l'opinion puis qui
viennent andré parfois c'est très rare
puis ils viennent à un truc à l'oreille
zehst est pensé qu'ils pourraient le
faire comme ça je fais puis ça change
tout tout à coup c'est une idée une tout
le monde à sa façon de commenter le
travail que ce soit le mien comme acteur
ou celui des autres où on est tous non
un groupe qu'ils ont créés
collectivement
le but c'est que c'est pas d'épargner
les ego des uns et des autres c'est de
faire le meilleur film possible le
meilleur le meilleur dont on soit
capable donc alors on va regarder
ensemble
des images un court extrait de ce très
réussie mathias et maxime c'est le jeu
ici vous avez le droit de parler
évidemment de commenter tout nous
raconter les question vous est posée en
tant que cinéaste
pour cette scène là tels frais oui on
est prêt la viande de toute façon on se
bat ventes ont dépassé la phase i non ne
résiste pas
vendredi la valise mais cette salle mais
elle représentative de à peu près 70 %
du film qui tournait à l'épaule à deux
caméras avec des slaps zone donc un zoom
très rapide 24 70 milliman je pense où
on 11 ou même sous merdes constamment
pour essayer de suivre un peu l'énergie
de deux des protagonistes qui sont assez
jeunes qui vivent une vie très rythmée
pour nécessairement un style et une
certaine violence aux faits mais une
forme de vie et d'énergie pour soi
coller au plus près à l'énergie que
dégage lire les personnages t on voulait
que la caméra
cette fois 6 et 7 d'avoir l'élégance de
deux prix de mettre la priorité sur les
humains et non pas de cesser de se
mettre en valeur à travers des longue
élaboration arte qui formaient les
gelées j'ai fait des films qui ont été
je pense plus affectées plus
mouvementées puis le j'avais envie de
quelque chose de plus dynamique mais mes
deux plus représentatif du film plus
aligné avec avec le coeur du film qui
sont les personnages le fait mais l'on
fasse sur les sur les personnages je
voulais pas qu'elle de contradictions en
fait formels entre le film et nous ce
qu'on fait parce que je j'ai découvert
au cours de ma vingtaine que j'aime pas
nécessairement les lits les films où on
sent qu'il ya un groupe qui a une
division entre les acteurs conques on
regarde ton film qu'on met en scène
depuis qu'on raconte piles et les puis
la caméra qui elle semble perdu de façon
plus insulaire dans sa propre mise en
scène son propre mouvement
je voulais que ce soit organique qui que
ce soit surtout solide que que nous
formellement soit solidaire pour moi ce
qui était important dans ce film c'était
de montrer le sentiment de collectivités
de ces jeunes garçons qui ont leurs
blagues depuis toujours leur inside du
jour puisque plus que peut-être
certains comprendront pas nécessairement
envoyer en vue mais ça m'est égal je
voulais qu'on concentre que cette ville
leur appartient que c'est ce monde cet
univers qui se sont créées pour se
protéger des années ou qui viennent pas
forcément des mêmes classes sociales
même l'environnement des merdes univers
certains sont à l'université d'autres
travaillent dans un long travail dans un
bar l'autre est avocat l'autre est
mécanicien mais mais ensemble ils ont
quelque chose qui est uniforme ils ne
seront presque 1 1 et le film se
distingue je trouve aussi par sa langue
par ces expressions par ces idiomes
québécois très assumé dans votre
filmographie c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs pour la différence de langue
de langage je me suis posé la question
après un film avec des stars françaises
après un film avec des stars
hollywoodiennes c'est un retour au
canada ce film aussi avec des acteurs
locaux proches de vous vous m'avez
confié avec un plus petit budget de
quelle envie ce que ça participe ça pour
vous au moins me laisse beaucoup c'est
un retour c'est un restaurateur mais
j'ai jamais quitté montréal
tout ce temps j'ai tourné juste la fin
de monde chez moi avec mes amis avec les
artistes qui m'entourent depuis le début
qui me protège qui me critique qui me
remettent en question
je n'ai besoin de vannes oc j'ai emmené
apprend qu'ils en aient à londres puis
après les acteurs ont pas vraiment
d'origine cdc des gens qui ont une
passion surtout puisque ce qui les
détermine qui les définit le mieux donc
ponctué en dessous d'une certaine depuis
en temps normal finalement il ya juste
deux femmes qui veulent très bien faire
leur métier qui ont un souci du détail
et puis rien d'autre donc ce film là est
un retour oui et non j'ai pas fait ce
film bloc en réponse à autre chose
il n'est pas fait en verre ou contre un
autre film ou l'insuccès d'un autre film
je les fais parce que j'avais envie de
parler d'amitié
tout simplement parce que à ce moment ci
dans ma vie à la fin de ma vingtaine je
me suis fait des amis qui sont devenus
très importants pour moi puis simon
mon qui mon team hm qui m'ont sauvé la
vie qui m'ont inspiré d'une façon
tellement oui mais ce sont veut qu'on
voit dans le film c'est à vila oui c'est
ses meilleures amies c'est les gens avec
qui je ris avec qui je déconne avec qui
je pleure aussi avec qui on déteste
certaines choses on en à bord d'autres
on est on est cinq rod est on est on est
ensemble en quelque chose puis on a
chacun nos opinions chacun nous venons
vie mais je les écris dans notre dossier
de presse du film n'ont peut-être que
ces essais itératif de l'ulm de le
redire le mais finalement j'ai fait des
films à la fin de ma vingtaine tout au
long d'un vingtaine mais surtout dans
les cinq dernières années ce jeu je me
suis fait des amis puis j'avais envie de
leur rendre hommage
voilà
un film votre personnage a une tache de
naissance roumaine qui semble couler de
votre oeil sur votre joue c'est la
marque de quelle douleur xavier écoute
j'ai toujours été fasciné par les par
les tâches de les taches de vin les
taches de naissance j'ai touche je
voulais en avoir une dans tom à la ferme
et puis finalement je trouvais sense
traction que c'était comme un truc qu'il
dé marquer de façon inélégante de
l'autre personnage masculin j'avais pas
envie de ça et puis j'ai vu des images
de son image de tâches de taches de vin
que je me disais c'est quelqu'un qui ont
dans une pièce des kinés manche une
immense tâche de mener manche immense
tâche de naissance
on sent quand même le bagage émotionnel
psychologique d'une personne qui
forcément à l'école s'est fait traiter
de exil et x on sent qu'il ya une
faiblesse mais une douleur quelque chose
et puis j'avais envie que le personnage
de maxime porte ça et puis qu'on voit
aussi qu'il est par le groupe d'amis
accepté comme tel comme qui est trouvé
avec eux à travers eux sont les ans cet
âge et renaissance lost est un petit peu
aussi un bagage personnel que moi j'ai
c'est compliqué de célestine emon dans
ces dernières années et il le l'amour le
triomphe le rejet la haine le c'est un
univers qui très contradictoires dans
toutes les dix que tim dichotomie le ya
énormément de solides se dit beaucoup de
bridgeurs puis cette tache de naissance
le pour moi avec ce groupe d'individus
autour c'est comme une espèce de c'était
aussi comme une espèce de métaphore
c'est des gens qui m'ont acceptée pic mo
inclus comme comme un des leurs thomas
tient ses maximes xavier la réalisatrice
du court métrage où le cas votre
personnage ou se nomme eric arrive est
alors vous allez me dire je suis pas
très original mais j'ai vu des clins
d'oeil
non non non pas du tout et n'aurait rick
romera jacques rivette je sais mais non
non on me le dit après que j'ai fait un
nom c'est un hasard désolé j'ai réduit
ma forme et mon manque de culture qui
ayant encore une fois votre manque de
culture savait pas d'époque mais c'est
passionnant que vous disiez ça parce que
c'est vrai que vos films très tôt ont
été salués dans les festivals européens
cannes venir
ce qu'ils sont un peu les temples de la
cinéphilie européenne classique et pour
autant vous le disiez tout à l'heure
vos cinémas empruntent aussi à une
culture populaire au soap opéra à la
variété à la télé réalité et vous dites
souvent que votre enfance c'est pas
godard ou nanni moretti qui nous a percé
mais c'est titanic est justement un film
remarquable
s'il en est comment est ce que vous
ressentez le regard justement qu'on
porte sur vous sur votre cinéma est ce
que vous trouvez en décalage souvent
avec ce que vous êtes le regard que les
gens portent sur nous mais c'est que
avant chaque film on se remet en
question à chaque film on apprend de nos
erreurs
il y en a toujours des nouvelles
toujours des plus grosses toujours des
plus gênantes au moins idéalement c'est
d'avant sont pas réitérés mais on est un
calcul mathématique émotif ou avec nan
ci notamment même n'a pas de prix je
trie mes amis on se pose des questions
comment on peut aller à madrid sur
pleins comment on peut aller ailleurs
qu'est ce que je veux changer
comment on peut oui mon chef opérateur
comment on peut tu vois ce film ci a été
tourné avec andré comme sur l'opérateur
mais avec un autre chef opérateur et
lise bélanger qui est le chef opérateur
de jean marc lalique fait bigler
d'onlive chape objects serait du bio il
vient de faire de muse de clint eastwood
c'est un cadreur hors pair et je savais
que le film serait fait à l'épaule
j'avais envie de son énergie j'avais
envie de son de son humour artistes à
présent sur le plateau
et puis ensemble ça crée un genre de
triumvirat tout on se bousculait
constamment et émotivement
intellectuellement est ce qu'on fait
c'est un nom qu'elle planqueel quelle
caméra qu'elle et puis on se pose
toujours des nouvelles questions d'un
point de vue visuel
je voulais aller par une une palette de
couleurs plus pastel que le feu ne soit
plus doux qui existait une plus grande
douceur qui sont criards que les autres
que l'émotion soit didier autrement si
autrement on a chaque film je le fais
après les gens le voient parfois tx10
bois c'est la même chose
non c'est un film de lui c'est pareil
les couleurs sont les mêmes pays nous
techniquement formellement fait non
c'est l'un et des couleurs profondes
bleu marine
ou ou noir ou vert forêt ou puis tout à
coup on est dans un truc plus les mêmes
rose corail on
je sais moi que je veux aller ailleurs
de film en film puis plus que jamais
j'ai voulu le faire pour moi ça c'est
max et c'est passionnant nous entendre
parler de textures justement et je sais
vous aviez que votre film sera diffusé à
cannes
pas n'importe comment non il sera
comment en 35 mm qu'est ce que ça change
ça change tout ça change tout c'est
c'est vous parlais juste avant d'avoir
cette question vous allez y le mot
textures pour moi texture saveurs
détails
puis les détails la texture pour moi
c'est ce qui fait d'un cil main stinky
possède émotivement ou visuellement un
relief puis sans relief les scènes sont
pleins il tombe à plailly on les voit on
les aime puis après sont les ramenons
les rapports pas forcément avec nous à
la maison pour en parler à ceux qu'on
aime pour le relief la texture ccc ce
qui donne un je ne dis pas que les films
tournés en digital j'en vois plein puis
ils sont magnifiques qui serait salué
récemment le film de céline sciamma vous
avez vu là parce que j'ai trouvé
tellement maîtrisé tellement
impressionnant tellement mais pour moi
quand il
quand je me pose la question en fait je
me pose jamais j'aime tourné en 35 mm
parce que c'est la vie c'est là c'est
c'est pas juste la magie ont tout autant
la magie sa remise c'est vrai que c'est
magique c'est imprévisible c'est donc
quelque chose tu vois les bleus tu dois
développer puisse faire c'est que ça
donne mais on pensait que ça vous arrive
encore ça d'être surpris oui mais ça
arrive toujours pas ce que le film c'est
vivant c'est un indice est une émulsion
c'est chimique s'est encore et la vie
ces cellules ces deux-là celluloïd
cellulaire on prend un pixel
on prend un pixel d'une de d'un d'une
image digitale con qu'on a grandi par
dix mais l'on voit un carré et puis on
le fait avec un pixel de 2 35 mm ce
qu'on voit c'est des cellules et on
comprend justement que le sens de vos
films va de pair avec une forme et c'est
peut-être une des raisons pour
lesquelles vous êtes scénariste
producteur réalisateur costumier acteurs
monteur j'en oublie peut-être c'est
toujours comme ça qu'il faudrait
envisager un film pour vous comment je
peux pas envisager le mais ces deux
réalisations quand on a un oeil sur rien
ou sur la moitié des choses ou qu'on dit
non ça c'est le département d'un autre
ou non ça c'est une job de ça c'est un
boulot de femmes ça c'est un boulot de
socié c'est la pire connerie de ses
costumes ça n'intéresse que n'ont cessé
pour moi un réalisateur une réalisatrice
doit avoir les mains dans tout doit
toucher à tout pour moi la pire chose
c'est le manque de curiosité c'est ça
tue la qualité à le remercier pour sa
curiosité merci pour le tout et merci
pour la vie s'avérer la ccig merci merci
à vous xavier votre film mathias et
maxime a été présenté aujourd'hui en
compétition vous souhaite évidemment de
le retrouver au palmarès merci à toutes
et à tous d'avoir suivi cet entretien
tout de suite la suite